surely gerglich good luck to you let's
get it going good luck
all right we're black here
knight f3
knight c6
we'll probably see a royal lopez here
could also see an italian game the
scotch game we have an italian game
okay
we'll play knight f6
and now i'm i'm expecting d3 because
if he plays yeah
if he plays anything other than d3 then
i would have been very
very very happy
knight g5
going into the fried liver
attack it is playable but
it can be very very tricky for white
so i would i would be very happy going
into that we'll play bishop c5
we'll have a nice joyco pinissimo
surely
gurglish
what's wrong with other with stuff other
than d3 like c3
uh well if you play c3
i think that just hangs upon
although maybe it's playable maybe c3 is
playable okay we see bishop g5 i don't
think this is one of the main moves i
think one of the main moves is
either c3 or castles
so i'm happy to see this bishop g5
okay
we'll start with d6
protecting this pawn
buffalo saying
so basically all i have to do is not
make one move mistakes i think i can
improve to a better rating
yeah that is that is one way to get to a
better rating
single elimination is kind of lame
single elimination can be exciting
double elimination is
it's like single elimination but
it's like twice as exciting
um
twice as exciting
right
we're gonna play a6
this does a couple things
first we can drop our bishop back if we
need to
and second of all
we're taking away the b5 square from his
bishop
so we want to play knight a5 and pick up
his bishop pair
but if we did it right away he would
have been able to play
bishop b5 to a4 then c3 and bishop c2
so we wouldn't have been able to get his
bishop now he makes an escape square for
his bishop
it's possible he's watching the stream
but
um
you know that's okay if he wants to do
that then
he can do that
i'm not going to be hiding anything
because i want i want to try to make
this an instructive experience
so
we're just gonna
play the best that we can
play the best that we can try to make
things as instructive as possible
he makes some space for his bishop
as well
thinking about playing h6
here
h6 he backs up the bishop
and we could play g5
it's very aggressive
hmm
[Music]
we if
we do that he'll probably sack i'll
probably sacrifice
we could also play bishop e6
and we're happy if he takes because
these are good double pawns
why are they good doubled pawns so
we don't mind these doubled pawns
because
this pawn on e6
controls
two very important squares which are f5
and d5
right
and you can imagine if white got a
knight to either of these squares
maybe later in the game especially if g5
has already been played
it could be very very annoying for
black
so if black has a pawn on this square
then it
it opens the opportunity to playing c5
and g5 without giving up these squares
and this pawn is very well protected
so
um we're not really at risk of
losing it right it's not like the e file
is going to open up right these pawns
are stuck
anyway
and we may even be able to play d5 later
and it just strengthens the center
so yeah that's that's why they're good
doubled pawns the short reason is it
strengthens the center right and that's
going to be really important
and the long reason
is uh well i just explained it
yep and the open f file yeah i forgot
about that it also opens the f-file if
we castle
right but i can't decide right now we'll
start with h6 just a nice
improving move
i'm not expecting him to take
it's obviously
it will obviously be very nice if he
does take
but i don't think he should and i'm not
expecting him to
he probably has better time management
than me so far you really should not
have already spent a sixth of your time
by move seven in
such a simple position
um
okay he moves back to e3
which is a little surprising to me
but
that's okay
now
leave our bishop here for now
we might even play knight g4 and
encourage him to take this
we could play bishop e6 ourselves
or one thing we could do is play b5 and
bishop b7 and i think that is gonna be
good i think i want my bishop developed
along
this long diagonal only thing
i maybe should be concerned about is
this bishop coming to d5 but i think it
should be okay
we play bishop b7
and i think i want to play c5 probably
sometime i could also play knight d4
here but then he might take twice and
play f4
and
these pawns on f4 and e4 they would
they'd be a little bit menacing maybe
two menacing
for me i don't know if i
want to deal with that right now
we'll start with b5
see where he puts this bishop
probably follow this up with bishop b7
up into them later in the game
which
opens the opportunity for black to play
g5 and c5 later in the game
and even d5
and it opens the f file for
the rook to attack right so we would not
want to take
on e3 because
white would then control the f4 and d4
squares and have the half open f-file
for their rook
and we would not really be able to
attack this pawn very easily right we
can attack it once
and that's really it white can defend we
really won't be able to attack this it's
not really a weakness we can attack
okay um this is fine
and e5
maybe
is
maybe going to be
weak
that was my main concern about allowing
this trade but
i think overall it will be fine
i could play queen d6
am i worried about c4
not at all
it creates a huge weakness for him
oprah protect e5
yeah i think that's what i'm gonna do
i'll play queen d6
castles and probably rookie 8
rook fe8 and rook a d8
and i'll decide where i want this bishop
i'm still not exactly sure where i want
this bishop
but
we'll start with
queen d6
maintaining pressure on the d pawn so he
can't immediately push c3
and over protecting e5
maintaining this
d-file pressure
there's one thing that i am keeping in
mind long term which is
these pawns are right now they're on
light squares
and this one is on a dark square and
it's very possible that we end up with a
structure kind of like this
and that will probably favor me in the
end game
but that structure will certainly favor
me in the end game because
we have the light squared bishop so we
want our pawns on dark squares for the
end game
shout out to continuity
well
if i play bishop g4 he'll play knight e3
i could play knight d4
he's probably going to play knight e3
that's what i would think
he wants to hop in to one of these
squares
so i could play knight d4
i'll play c3
i don't really want my bishop on g6 it's
not gonna do anything on this diagonal
if i put it on b7 i allow him to hop
into f5
which is also
very unideal
very unideal i could play knight d4
this allows for the option of playing c6
he'll just play c3 though
i would have to take
probably don't want to do that
there there
takes
takes
knight d4
he has to come back
i've also got this move b4
but that move doesn't have a threat it
really
doesn't do anything
looking at some knight maneuvers
he can play you can simply play g3 to
stop it
which probably doesn't do much i don't
know maybe we do put our bishop on g6
we allow him to play g4
feels wrong because then
he takes us his pawns are already
connected
we play g6
what's wrong with us doing that
we're just weakening our king side
might have some long-term implications
h4h5
g6 h4 we then have bishop g4 knight e3
bishop e6
kind of stumped at what to do here
it might seem like a simple position but
white's got some serious plans that i
don't want to just
allow him to do
knight d4
he plays c3 knight d4 c3 takes takes
with a queen bishop g4
queen g3
probably not it's probably not good
if we castle king side we're we might
get pawn stormed
we don't have a good way of opening up
the center
bishop i need i'm having trouble with
this bishop
bishop b7
bishop e6 it forces him to take
he gets a knight to f5
and we can play 97.
it doesn't really force him to take but
if he doesn't take then his rook is a
little bit misplaced will definitely be
annoying for him later
okay
we will take
misplace his rook
and play 97
to stop the knight from coming to an
annoying square
is that too passive
knight f5
knight f5 really
must be stopped does it does it have to
be stopped
could play g6 that's the other way of
stopping it
it allows knight h4
probably g6 it's actually
better we might even castle queen side
here in this game
g6 stopping knight f5 i'm happy i'm
happy with how i spent my time there i
thought that was a critical moment
you may maybe you'd disagree but
uh i i thought it was important to spend
the time there whole position feels kind
of rough now i feel good about it
i feel
i i think it's a great position for us
actually
love our nice little pawn chain here
we have a great pawn structure what are
you talking about
our pawn
pawn structure is fantastic
it is fantastic now i'm thinking we play
knight d4
yeah this feels like a very typical
joyco pinissimo
type pawn structure
except there's no bishops left
which should benefit black
because there's no bishop on this
diagonal which is often very very strong
and white's rook is misplaced so overall
i'm happy with the position
i think this is our plan
but if you play c3
that is going to be annoying because we
don't really want to take
so maybe we start with
do we castle queenside
or do we play rook d8
that's basically the question right now
if we castle queen side he plays a4 we
have to play b4 to keep the a file
closed
then we can't really
i mean we can't really play c4 which is
probably not going to be super good so
i'm thinking
i like rook d8 more
if he could still castle queenside
it would be a much harder decision
because
then he might castle queenside
and try to storm me on the king side
because my king's side is weaker and i
think
i would not want to go into that
but since he can't castle queenside
anymore he's either stuck in the center
or stuck going king side if we both
castle kingside a pawn storm on the king
side from him will
be much less effective it will it will
either be much less effective as an
attack or it will just be bad for him
continue applying pressure to the
position with our pieces we might play
knight d4 next
move
because then he can't play c3 that's one
of the benefits of rook d8
now if knight t4 c3 we just take
i guess there's actually queen takes and
our
knight is hanging this is actually still
quite tricky
where do i put my king now that i've
played h6 and g6 yeah king side is still
fine
king's side is
still very fine here
i think i sort of answer that question
already
um
h7 slash g7
should be
fairly safe squares in a lot of these
lines
okay they castle
we have this move c4
c4 takes
takes
takes
takes takes takes
takes takes
if a4 we play b4
e5 is still defended
kind of just breaking down the center
and
that looks good to me
c4
clarifying things
his rook is still misplaced i think i
like it i think i like it
if he plays d4 we can take that
right
i think we can
what if he takes with a knight we take
here
takes takes
rookie one
we can play f5
that should be fine that should be
really good
okay let's go for it c4
perfect
perfect though
castle before opening the center
normally that is what you want to do
but
if the center opens up right now we're
going to be getting a queen trade anyway
so our king will be
fine in center or it'll actually be
beneficial for our king to be in the
center
and if he doesn't then
we can always castle in one move
our kings should be fairly safe so if we
can win a pawn
and then castle and be super safe
then
i'm definitely super okay with that as
well
one
move they may be considering is knight
e1
but then i think i can take on e4
well i probably take here first
and then i then i'd take on e4
and that would win a pawn
i think we should definitely trade
queens
the queen trade will benefit us
for the reason we just said our king is
still in the center so if we can get to
the end game
the king in the center should be
beneficial
his rook
still
out of play here
we should take this
perfect
the benefit of all of these trades is
our king's still in the center
we undouble our pawns
his rook is
out of play
get a very nice active knight he has a
passive knight
this should be slightly better for black
if he pushes a4 my original plan was
just to push b4
but it gives him a past pawn a connected
pass pawn
i don't
know if i okay
he played knight e3
um i don't know if that is
actually a good move maybe i'll start
with f6 just controlling these knights
trying to control these knights
knight d5 and i can play
king d7
okay we'll start with f6
playing the end game here playing the
end game probably going for d5
yeah
white does get the three on two queen
side majority
they do
they do
gotta activate this guy i want to
activate my rook here
knight d5 that's a good question good
question knight d5 it's a very obvious
move i
expect him to play it when he plays
knight d5 we'll play
king d7 to defend our c7 spot f6 is
defended by
the knight on e4
and
we'll we'll be threatening king d6 so
if you play something like rook a1
we might have to play knight e7
because if we if uh if knight d5
king d7 rook a1 king d6 he just plays
rook d1
and we're screwed
so knight d5 king d7
rook a1 i don't expect him to play rook
a1
i think it's
probably not a super great move we could
also play rook h7
which is actually
it doesn't look like that bad of a move
uh but he's gonna play knight h4 if i do
this he might actually be able to sack
for these two pawns and get the three
connected pass pawns that would probably
be good
he'll play knight h4 next the nice thing
though is
he can't make any more progress after
knight h4 rook g8
what is he doing he can't do anything
else
on the king side
um
and then i'll be able to kick this
knight out of here and it should be
fine
should be fine
king d7 got to protect this c7 spot i'm
just noticing now that he wants to play
f3 and eat my knight and when my knight
is eaten his knight is also defended so
i might be losing a pawn unless i play
g5 so how can i counter attack now okay
we may have blundered a pawn we can
attack both spots
okay he can still play
immediately f3 here which might be
[Music]
tricky except maybe he can't because
then both of his ponies would be
attacked why not just 97 then if f3 you
just trade knights their pawns become
less coordinated if i played knight e7
then he can do the simple
knight takes e7 and i can't take back
because knight takes g6 is a fork on my
king and my rook
right
i can't take back
so that would be a big problem
that's why i didn't play 97.
yeah
okay
so this is going to force one of the
knights back to e3
is that correct
is that correct that should be beautiful
he'll probably move the f knight back to
e3 so that he maintains the c7 pressure
and then
i'll probably do something like this
to keep this guy defended followed by
knight d4
and i think this should be good we've
got the weak spot defended
this spot is a little hard to target we
can always push it to h5 and we're gonna
get this guy on c7 rolling
soon we've got very active knights a
rook soon to be activated hopefully it
can be activated faster than his rook
which i think it will be able to
definitely a sharp end game here
sharp end game can't recommend queen
takes f2 checkmate
oh my goodness i totally didn't even see
that move
didn't even see that move
yeah it's just
you shouldn't suggest moves just
to try to
respect the players of the game like if
you guys suggest a move that i didn't
see
then it's just a really bad situation
because if i play it
that's kind of unfair to my opponent i
think we just go with rook h7 right keep
some defense here
a4b4 knight c4
i'm not worried about this
this knight
needs to
hold some defense move i might be
worried about his knight b4 i certainly
can't trade that there i'd probably play
knight d4
but maybe we'll play knight a5 looking
to come into c4
is f5 a potential move i feel like it
might be
threaten f4 you can move this
horse
the pony
knight b4 is really his only escape but
if he plays a4b for spawn to c4 then he
solidifies
the knight which might not be good but
then we play knight a5
c6
that should be okay even then the knight
actually gets trapped
knight b6 rook b7
knight c8 king d7 the knights trapped
the knight would have to come to a8
and then the knight is
still trapped
it might take a while to win
we would maybe not we maybe be able to
win the night what does knight a5 do
the main purpose of knight a5 for black
is
remaneuvering the knight to
uh c4
oh but in the line that in the
calculation that i was saying
um so
b4 pawn c4 knight a5
uh it pressures c4 and it prevents b3
and it blocks a4 so that's actually
those are the three reasons why knight
a4
um
is to be played because then this knight
is tied down to the pawn so i then i
might have ideas of f5 f4 to kick the
knight away and then i take this and the
knight's hanging i'm feeling good about
the position
our pawns are further advanced our king
is more active our rook is
more active so i think if either side
has an advantage here it's probably
black
okay we cannot allow the a file to open
so we must play b4 i hope that move
wasn't a blunder says knight trapped now
are we
so what might happen here is
um if this knight moves he loses this
knight this knight can't move anywhere
safely and he can't stop f4
so he's actually losing a knight here
but i'm gonna have to sack my knight for
his apon
so
it's really just a trade
it's one of those
fancy trades
so this is
probably going to be good for me
but i i can't say much about this i'm
curious to see how this will
pan out
i'm also curious to see the computer
evaluation at the end of this
game oh shoot
i just realized um
takes takes
he has this move
and
we have two knights for the rook so
that's actually okay
i actually didn't see this move knight
takes b4
until after i had played f4 but should
be okay okay the other move is takes
here
takes you immediately so takes push
takes there
sorry sorry sorry we wouldn't do that
takes
takes
push
rook a1 takes takes takes
king f1
rook f7 doesn't work
dang f7 is like
what we really would want to play
so takes takes takes
there
there there
there i think that's okay takes takes
takes
push he comes back there
there
that should be good
okay we'll take
because we're gonna get a queen too here
maybe
if he lets us you think the computer's
gonna say three thousand blunders
i always
hope for no blunders
because if you if you play a game with
no blunders
zero zero zero
that always feels really good but
on the other blunders are not bad
because
with every blunder every blunder is a
learning opportunity blunders are not
necessarily bad
okay
well we'll take with the pawn
i think this should be winning after
king d6 because now our plan is rook f7
knight g3
and the secondary plan is rook f7 knight
d2 which is not checkmate but we still
get a queen right so if he tries to stop
our primary plane we've still got the
backup plan and king d6 is an important
first move to make because we need to
avoid knight d8 so if he continues here
with a7 we obviously won't take the
knight
we'll just play rook f7 and then we're
threading checkmate in one
so he can't promote and this should be
good i'm curious to
see
like how much
stronger do i actually play
when i'm actually
focusing a hundred percent of my focus
on the game because obviously whenever
you're streaming
not a hundred percent of your focus is
on the game some of it is on your stream
even if it's a very small amount
that is um that's actually an incredibly
good move that i missed oh no
okay
we may be putting in the sack here
bros
we might be putting in the sack
a7 rook f7
that's brilliant
it's a nice tactic
it's a nice tactic
but right now he can just play
that move
can he
okay we'll play king e7
knight c6 king f6
rook a1
we've got rook d2
but then he's he's actually got g4 which
i missed that move
we may have just blundered because i
missed g4 hopefully
i think all we can do now is hope
but i think
he might see it
he's playing pretty well
okay well
um
now we still have the option to take the
knight
we play here he plays g4
there
takes
oh i think we won i think we just won
the game right
did we not just win the game
because it's a discovered double check
and the queen is protected
sweet
[Music]
all right
what's up what's up rook to you too
d2
there we go
you can throw in one check but
i don't think it does anything
g4 check
there check
takes
checkmate
i don't think you can stop that
even get the queen
a8 queen can we checkmate down a queen
was it luck
i think that's a good philosophical
question
um i think there is some element of luck
in chess
i think this game we did get a tiny bit
lucky but i think for the most part
there was little luck
in this game
it feels super lucky
sometimes these really really sharp
positions can feel really lucky but
that's just
the nature of sharp positions
he's insane
okay just double checking here i'm not
blundering anything i don't think it
matters d6 or f6 i don't think it
matters
because we've got our forced checkmate
so it shouldn't matter there are no
checks
check
check
we did not get the checkmate
that's okay
surely gurglish
good game
good game
all right
really good game
all right
wow yeah this was a
very nice
game
very nice game and we made some blunders
for the most part the beginning of the
game was very accurate though
which is nice so let's take a look
okay
this is all
all theory here
d6
a6
a3 h6
b5
and as of b5 is a completely new game
it's a b5 bishop takes c5d takes c5
this structure might look a little bit
weird if you're not used to it and i
will admit that
i used to think this structure was bad
for black
but then i faced it a couple times
and my opponents actually
they
survived pretty well
and i was like oh maybe it's not so bad
so i looked into it and it's not that
bad so now i play it
the computer agrees computer thinks it's
completely fine
queen d6 this was all
it was all good from both of us
and castling was his first mistake
a small inaccuracy
and i had an opportunity with
oh i had i could have won a pawn
i missed winning a pawn
with queen e6
because
the rook is hanging and then i can play
knight takes e4
oh
i missed that one it's a discovered pin
and an attack on the rook
so a
small missed tactic there
best move by a tiny bit
and then you can grab the pawn not bad
not bad oh wow
and then you have to sacrifice the
exchange
well you have to
because otherwise you get forked
but
white has to sack the exchange back
wow
look at this line
what a crazy line
if white
saves the rook
then
there's knight g5
and the main
things about this position
are
the d4 square
and
this isolated d-pawn is definitely gonna
be a target for black later
so black has
like actually they're not actually down
any material they have a knight in two
pawns for the rook
and they've got this
really beautiful d4 square
so and and a really great
center in the palm uh
they've got this
black has got this really beautiful d4
square and a great center with the pawns
so okay
crazy line
that i did not see with queen e3
okay i played c4 though which is the
second best move
and this was good this was i think
an okay trade
and this was all good here
and here i played g5
but i could have played king d6
and
he would not have been able to take
actually
i actually
completely overlooked this move king d6
um
because if he takes i just play rook g8
and both of his knights are hanging so
he loses a piece
so i could have done this and then
then i would have been able to play
knight e7 because he doesn't have to
remove the defender tactic
so this would have been slightly better
g5 was a small mistake
knight fe3
i played rook h7
which was a small mistake by me
because it allowed this
sequence of moves which happened in the
game and he has f3
which
counter attacks my knight
and equalizes
now he could push or he could play
knight g4 and either are winning i would
have to sacrifice
my knight
and
i wouldn't be down any material here but
i would have this isolated pawn
and this
might be a weakness white's rook is
really active
as well
the knight restricts my king so
the engine gives slightly better for
white here
but they didn't go for that they went
for knight takes b4
which was the move that i was worried
about
but
um
turns out it was actually no good
and here
i should have played rook d7 straight
away
but it was because i missed
knight d8
but apparently rook a4 is also winning
which makes sense because i have to move
my knight
so i should have played rook d7 and this
was
this was a big time tactic
rook d7
the computer announces a checkmate in
nine
checkmated nine moves after rook a1
because of rook d2
we had this very similar mating net
so we did get a little bit lucky
with
this here he has to play rook a3
which is a really really difficult move
to find
right preventing knight g3
because now i can play king e7
not taking the knight
and it's just a checkmate in
a couple more moves there's nothing he
can do
oh no
my king